رغم معاناته لاكثر من عام كامل من مرض
السرطان واعتقاله لنحو الثلثي عمره
البالغي 50 عاما
تقرر اسرائيل احتجاز جثمان الاسير ناصر
ابو حميد وحرمان اهله من دفنه والقاء نظره
الوداع الاخيره عليه
هيئه الاسرار كانت قد حمل السلطات
الاحتلال مسؤوليه وفاته بسبب سياسه
الاهمال الطبي المتعمد في سجونها القرار
جاء من وزير الدفاع الاسرائيليانس بعد
تقدير من الموقف الامني وبتوصيات من
الجهات الامنيه والجيش وتذرعا بما وصفها
بيان صادر عن مكتبه بضرورات تتعلق
بالمفاوضات على عقد صفقه تبادل الاسرى
والمفقودين الاسرائيليين
الخطوه الاسرائيليه السرعان ما لاقت ردود
فعل فلسطينيه
ادانت القرار واعتبرته معانا في جريمه
الاحتلال بحق الشهيد اما حركه حماس فقالت
ان الاحتلال يخالف ابسط القوانين والاعراف
الدوليه وينتهي كل معايير حقوق الانسان في
حين وصف الامين العام لحركه المبادره
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه مصطفى البرغوثي القرار
الاسرائي هي بالمجرم وحمل المجتمع الدولي
مسؤوليه الصمت اما عائله الاسير ناصر ابو
حميد فقررت عدم فتح بيت عزاء لنجلها الا
بعد ان تقوم ما سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بالافراج عن جثمانه ليدفن حسب عاداته
وتقاليد الفلسطينيين
وقيامنا ويكون
وارسل يليق بقائد مناضل مثل ناصر ابو حميد
لا يعد احتجاز وجثامين الشهداء والاسرى
الفلسطينيين سياسه جديده للسلطات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي فهي حتى الان تحتجث ميناء 10
اسرار قضوا خلف زنازينها فضلا عن جثامين
نحو 90 شهيدا سقطوا خلال اشتباكات وعمليات
عسكريه في الضفه الغربيه منذ عوده الجيش
الاسرائيلي للسياسه احتجاز الجثامين عام